[MUSIC PLAYING]
BUKOLA AYODELE:
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you how
Cloud Key Management can
help you manage encryption
keys on Google Cloud.
Cloud Key Management allows you
to create, import, and manage
cryptographic keys and perform
cryptographic operations
in a single, centralized
cloud service.
Cloud Key Management
allows you to centrally
manage symmetrical and
asymmetrical encryption
keys for your cloud services
the same way you do on-premises.
You can generate, use,
rotate, and destroy
these cryptographic keys.
Cloud Key Management
allows you to enable
hardware key security with a
Hardware Security Model, HSM.
You can toggle between
software and hardware-protected
encryption keys with
a press of a button.
You can also encrypt
data in BigQuery,
and Compute Engine,
and other services
with encryption keys that
are stored and managed
in a third-party key management.
External Key Manager allows you
to keep your encryption keys
on-prem while still
leveraging the power of cloud
for compute and analytics.
Cloud Key Management
is very easy to setup.
You can either enable Cloud Key
Management services in Google
Cloud Console or use the API.
The pricing model is simple.
It is a pay-as-you-go model,
and you are charged based
on different products you
use in Cloud Key Management.
So next time you're looking
to manage encryption keys,
take a minute to look
at Cloud Key Management.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/security-key-management
[MUSIC PLAYING]